THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON ENERGY,
UTILITIES AND COMMUNICATIONS
WILL COME TO ORDER. I WANT TO
SAY GOOD MORNING. AND WE'RE
HOLDING OUR MEETING IN ROOM 1200
ON THE Þ STREET BUILDING. AND
WE'RE ASKING ALL MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE TO BE PRESENT IN ROOM
1200 SO WE CAN ESTABLISH A
QUORUM. WE ONLY HAVE ONE MEASURE
ON TODAY'S AGENDA, AND THAT IS
OUR, H.R. 18 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
DAVIES AND WE WILL START AT Ã
AS A SUBCOMMITTEE, IF THAT'S ALL
RIGHT, WITH OUR MEMBERS HERE.
AND, ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAVIES,
WHEN YOU'RE READY, YOU MAY BEGIN.
OKAY GOOD MORNING. I FIRST WANT
TO SAY THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
TAKING THE TIME OUT TO HEAR OUR
BILL. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR.
TODAY, I'M HERE TO PRESENT A JRE
18 MEMBERS BACK IN 1998, THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WAS LEGALLY
OBLIGATED TO WORK WITH STATES
WHO HAD NUCLEAR FACILITIES IN
THEIR STATE TO FIND SAFE AND
SECURE PLACES TO STORE EXCESS
NUCLEAR FUEL. CALIFORNIANS, AS
YOU KNOW, HAS AND HAD FACILITIES
IN SACRAMENTO, SAN LUIS OBISPO,
SAN DIEGO AND HUMBOLDT COUNTIES.
AFTER MORE THAN 25 YEARS, WE ARE
STILL WAITING. NOTHING HAS BEEN
DONE AND OUR COMMUNITIES ARE
SUFFERING FOR IT. AS NOTED BY
THE SUPPORTERS, AJ R 18, SINCE
2000, U.S. TAXPAYERS HAVE PAID
$10.6 BILLION IN DAMAGES TO
COVER COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH ON
SITE NUCLEAR STORAGE THAT HASN'T
BEEN MOVED YET. H.R. 18 IS QUITE
SIMPLE. IT'S SIMPLY IMPLORES THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO ENACT
POLICIES OUTLINED IN THE LATEST
BLUE RIBBON COMMISSION ON
AMERICA'S NUCLEAR FUTURE AND
FINALLY, GET THIS FUEL OUT OF
THE STATE AND TO CONSENT BASED
SITES APPROVED BY THE FEDERAL
DEPARTMENT OF ENERGY. SENATORS,
THE RESOLUTION IS NOT HERE TO
DEBATE THE MERITS OF NUCLEAR
ENERGY. IT IS A SIMPLE TOOL TO
SHOW THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THAT
THE WORLD'S FIFTH LARGEST
ECONOMY IS READY FOR THEM TO
START ACTING AND DO THE JOB THEY
HAVE BEEN NEGLECTING FOR OVER
TWO DECADES. THIS RESOLUTION
PASSED THE ASSEMBLY WITH NO NO
VOTES AND IS SUPPORTED BY
MULTIPLE CHAMBERS OF COMMERCE.
OUR STATE PARK FOUNDATION, US
SAN DIEGO, A LOCAL NATIVE
AMERICAN TRIBE, AND MANY OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS WITH ME HERE TO
TESTIFY IN, SUPPORT AND ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS. AS MANUEL
CAMARGO. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE ON H.R. 18. YOU HAVE
TWO MINUTES. GOOD MORNING,
MISTER CHAIR AND SENATORS. MY
NAME IS MANUEL CAMARGO, AND I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON AND THE SPENT
FUEL SOLUTIONS COALITION
ADVOCATING FOR THE PASSAGE OF
H.R. 18 TODAY SPENT NUCLEAR FUEL
IS STRANDED AT MORE THAN 70
SITES IN 34 STATES, INCLUDING
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. CALIFORNIANS
ALONE HAVE PREPAID APPROXIMATELY
$2 BILLION FOR THE DISPOSAL OF
SPENT FUEL. DUE TO THIS, WE NEED
SOLUTIONS NOW AND WE MUST AVOID
PASSING THIS PROBLEM ON TO THE
NEXT GENERATION OF CALIFORNIANS.
WE MUST AMEND THE NUCLEAR WASTE
POLICY ACT TO PROVIDE FOR A
DURABLE SPENT FUEL MANAGEMENT
PROGRAM THAT PROVIDES FOR BOTH
NEAR-TERM STORAGE AND THE LONG
TERM DISPOSAL OF SPENT NUCLEAR
FUEL. H.R. 18 WILL HELP SEND A
STRONG MESSAGE TO CONGRESS AND
CALL ATTENTION TO THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE. WITH YOUR SUPPORT, WE
WILL COMPEL THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO DELIVER SOLUTIONS
FOR THOSE REASONS. I URGE YOU TO
PLEASE VOTE AYE ON THIS
RESOLUTION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT STATE YOUR NAME AND YOUR
ORGANIZATION. SEEING NONE.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. IF
YOU'RE THE PRIMARY WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION, YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES. HI. MY NAME IS BILL
ALEO WITH THE ENVIRONMENTAL
WORKING GROUP AND REPRESENTING A
NUMBER OF KHÓ SIGNEES TO OUR
LETTER. WE OPPOSED IN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED IN THE ASSEMBLY,
BUT THE AUTHOR DID NOT ACCEPT
OUR SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS. SO NOW
WE'RE JUST STRAIGHT OPPOSE THE
REASONS ARE SIMPLE AND ARE
STATED IN THE IN THE ANALYSIS.
ONE IS BY DOING CONSOLIDATED
STORAGE, YOU HAVE TO MOVE IT
TWICE, ONCE TO THE INTERIM PLACE
AND THEN TWICE AGAIN WHEN IT
GOES TO THE PERMANENT LOCATION,
WHEREVER THAT IS. SECONDLY THE
SIS SITES ARE USUALLY TRYING TO
BE LOCATED IN EJ OR
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. THIRD
IS INTERIM STORAGE REDUCES THE
PRESSURE TO ESTABLISH A
PERMANENT SOLUTION, WHICH HAS
BEEN WE'VE BEEN TRYING TO SEEK
THE NATION HAS BEEN TRYING TO
SEEK FOR EVER SINCE THE YUCCA
MOUNTAIN SITE WAS DISCARDED.
FOURTH, IT COULD BECOME A
PERMANENT LOCATION. SO WHEREVER
YOU PUT IT, BE CAREFUL. FIFTH IS
IT COULD BE ESTABLISHED RIGHT
HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND THEN MADE
PERMANENT SO IT COULD COME BACK
TO BITE CALIFORNIA, WHERE IF
WE'RE SAYING, YEAH, GET THIS
STUFF, GET IT OUT OF SAN ONOFRE
OR WHEREVER, IT COULD END UP IN
CALIFORNIA. THERE'S NOTHING IN
THIS RESOLUTION OR THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT SAYING IT HAS TO. IT
CAN BE BANNED FROM CERTAIN
PLACES. THEY'RE JUST LOOKING TO
DO IT. SO WHY NOT CALIFORNIA IN
THE LONG RUN? SO FOR THOSE
REASONS, WE OPPOSE THE
RESOLUTION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION OR IN SUPPORT HERE IN
ROOM 1200. HEARING AND SEEING.
NONE BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. ANY QUESTIONS BY THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS? SENATOR
NEWMAN, WILL YOU FIRST READ FOR
ME? ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. SO I WANT TO FIRST OF
ALL, THANK YOU FOR THE MEASURE.
I REQUEST TO BE ADDED AS A
COAUTHOR. IF IT GETS AMENDED
ALONG THE WAY, I SEE THAT
SENATOR BLAKE HAS ALREADY
CALLED. I VISITED THE FACILITY.
I'VE HAD EXTENSIVE CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE FOLKS INVOLVED THERE,
AND I'VE ACTUALLY TALKED TO
CONGRESSMAN MIKE LEVIN, WHO'S
ACTUALLY WORKING DILIGENTLY AT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL TRYING TO
SOLVE THIS PROBLEM. HOPEFULLY WE
GIVE HIM SOME HELP TO DO THAT,
BUT I WANT YOUR TAKE ON ONE OF
THE OBJECTIONS, THIS THIS
ASSERTION THAT AN INTERIM
STORAGE SITE IS LIKELY TO BE
LOCATED IN A COMMUNITY OF COLOR.
I MEAN, CERTAINLY THAT'S NOT OUR
PRACTICE CURRENTLY, NOR OUR
INTENT ON THIS. WOULD YOU MIND
SPEAKING TO THAT? YES. THANK
YOU. SENATOR, THE CURRENT BEST
PRACTICE AND THE PROGRAM
UNDERWAY BY THE U.S. DEPARTMENT
OF ENERGY AT PRESENT IS A
CONSENT BASED PROCESS. AND VERY
SIMPLY STATED, THAT MEANS THAT
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO SITE EITHER
AN INTERIM STORAGE FACILITY OR A
PERMANENT DISPOSAL FACILITY FOR
SPENT NUCLEAR FUEL, UNLESS THE
HOST COMMUNITY IS WELL INFORMED
AND WOULD LIKE TO HAVE IT THERE.
THAT IS, TO SAY THAT THEY THAT
THAT COMMUNITY SEES IT WILL BE
BETTER OFF FOR HOSTING THE
FACILITY. I APPRECIATE THAT. I
JUST WANT TO, YOU KNOW, GET THAT
EXPLICITLY ON THE RECORD HERE
TODAY, SO WITH THAT, GLAD TO
SUPPORT THE BILL. THANK YOU.
SENATOR WILK. YEAH. WE DON'T
HAVE TO GO TILL 930, SO I'M
GOING TO KILL A COUPLE OF
MINUTES. WHETHER YOU SUPPORT
NUCLEAR ENERGY OR NOT, THIS
MAKES SENSE. AND I HAPPEN TO
SUPPORT NUCLEAR ENERGY. AND I
TOURED JAPAN A NUMBER OF YEARS
AGO. AND AFTER THE 2011, 2011
TSUNAMI, THEY SHUT DOWN ALL 57
OF THEIR NUCLEAR POWER PLANTS.
AND THEN THEY REALIZED, WE'RE
NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO GO NET
ZERO WITHOUT NUCLEAR POWER. AND
SO WHEN I WAS THERE, THEY HAD
TEN BACKUP. TEN BACKUP ONLINE.
OTHERS IN THE PERMITTING
PROCESS. WE'RE GOING TO HAVE THE
SAME CHALLENGE HERE. AND TO HAVE
THIS DELAYED FOR OVER TWO
DECADES IS RIDICULOUS. SO IF
HOPEFULLY IT DOESN'T GET
AMENDED, BUT IF IT DOES GET
AMENDED, I'D LOVE TO BE ADDED AS
A COAUTHOR AS WELL. AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING THIS
FORWARD. MY PLEASURE. THANK YOU.
SENATOR MIN, THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. I APPRECIATE THIS
RESOLUTION. IT'S AN IMPORTANT
ONE. AS WE KNOW IN ORANGE
COUNTY, MOST OF OUR DISTRICTS,
MAYBE ALL OF OUR DISTRICTS, ARE
THREATENED BY THIS TICKING TIME
BOMB. WITH THE SPENT FUEL AT
SONGS. AND SO THIS IS A PROBLEM
WE'VE KNOWN ABOUT THIS PROBLEM
WE NEED TO ADDRESS IT. WE NEED
BOTH THE STATE AND THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO WORK TOGETHER TO
ADDRESS THIS IN A TIMELY WAY.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT MANY
HUNDREDS OF BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
IN POTENTIAL PROPERTY VALUE THAT
THAT POTENTIALLY COULD BE
DESTROYED. SO I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL. I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING IT
FORWARD. AND IF THERE IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO BE ADDED ON AS A
COAUTHOR, I TOO WOULD LIKE TO BE
ADDED. THANK YOU. SENATOR DODD.
YES. THANK YOU, YOU KNOW, OTHER
COUNTRIES HAVE FOUND THE ANSWER
TO THIS, TO THIS ISSUE. AND I'M
CONFIDENT THAT WE CAN, AS WELL.
I WAS MOST RECENTLY IN CANADA
AND IN THE PROVINCE OF QUEBEC,
AND THEY ARE BOUND AND
DETERMINED TO CONTINUE ON THEIR
NUCLEAR POWER, ADDITIONS THAT
OBVIOUSLY THEY DO A LOT OF HIGH
HYDRO, BUT THEY BELIEVE THAT
THEIR FUTURE FOR ADDITIONAL
POWER IS WITH NUCLEAR. IN
ADDITION TO THAT, I WAS, IN
FRANCE AND, LAST NOVEMBER AND WE
TOURED A NUCLEAR PLANT AND,
CLEARLY THE NUCLEAR SCIENTISTS
AND THE PEOPLE THAT WE SAW, EVEN
THE EVEN IN THE ENVIRONMENTAL
COMMUNITY, THEY'VE GOT, YOU
KNOW, SOME SYNERGY AROUND THIS
AND THEY JUST SIMPLY SAY, WE
CANNOT HIT OUR CARBON FREE GOALS
WITHOUT NUCLEAR. AND I JUST
THINK THIS IS AN EXAMPLE. WE
DON'T ALWAYS HAVE TO RECREATE
THE WHEEL ON HOW WE DO
EVERYTHING IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT WE SHOULD HAVE BEEN DOING A
LONG TIME AGO, AND IT'S HIGH
TIME THAT WE MOVE FORWARD. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS, WE HAVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR GROVE. OH
YEAH. YEAH, WE GOT TO ESTABLISH
A QUORUM. CAN WE FIRST ESTABLISH
A QUORUM? BRADFORD HERE.
BRADFORD HERE, DALLY HERE, DALLY
HERE. ASHBY. BECKER. BECKER
HERE. CABALLERO DODD HERE. DODD.
HERE. DURAZO. EGGMAN EGGMAN.
HERE. GONZALEZ. GROVE Ã. GROVE.
HERE. LEMON. MIN MIN. HERE
NEWMAN. HERE. NEWMAN. HERE.
RUBIO CIERTO. CIERTO. HERE.
SKINNER STERN. WILK. PRESENT.
WILK. PRESENT WE HAVE A QUORUM
AND I WOULD JUST, WANT TO, ECHO
SOME OF THE COMMENTS THAT MY
COLLEAGUE FROM NAPA HAS STATED.
I, TOO, HAVE VISITED NUCLEAR
PLANTS AROUND THE WORLD AND TO
DESCRIBE WHAT WE HAVE NOW AS A
TICKING TIME BOMB, I THINK IS A
LITTLE HYPERBOWL, WHERE IT IS
RIGHT NOW IS VERY SAFE. THE
QUESTION IS AGAIN, WHERE DO WE
MOVE IT TO? AND MOST COUNTRIES I
WAS IN DENMARK AND THE LOCAL
TOWN WAS LITERALLY FIGHTING,
BIDDING TO STORE THE NUCLEAR
WASTE. AND I SAID, WELL, IS IT A
TAX BREAK? I SAID, IS IT SOME
TYPE OF INCENTIVE FOR THE
COMMUNITY? IS IT GUARANTEED
JOBS? IT SAID, NO, WE FEEL IT'S
OUR RESPONSIBILITY IF THIS IS
OUR POWER SOURCE, WE'RE
OBLIGATED TO STORE THIS NUCLEAR
WASTE. SO I COMMEND THEM AND WE
SHOULD TAKE THAT APPROACH OF
SEEING NOT IN OUR BACKYARD, BUT
HOW DO WE STORE THIS SAFELY
REGARDLESS OF IT? AND WE SHOULD
BE HAPPY TO REPORT, WE HAVEN'T
HAD A NUCLEAR ACCIDENT OR ANY
KIND OF EXPOSURE SINCE THREE
MILE ISLAND IN 1979. SO THAT
TELLS YOU WE ARE DOING IT RIGHT.
WE'RE DOING IT SAFE. BUT YES,
FINDING A PERMANENT HOME FOR
THIS NUCLEAR WASTE IS IMPORTANT.
SO I COMMEND YOU FOR THIS
LEGISLATION. I JUST HAD A
QUESTION AS IT RELATES TO IT,
YOUR RESOLUTION MENTIONS H.J.R
29, BUT NOT SIMILARLY ADOPTED
H.J.R 23. WHY IS THAT? THAT WAS
CHÁVEZ WAS H.J.R 29, WAS CHÁVEZ
IN 2016? YEAH. HAVE NO
OPPOSITION TO THE TO THAT BILL
OR THAT RESOLUTION. AND,
HONESTLY, NO, NO REASON FOR THE
EXCLUSION. OKAY. ALL RIGHT. JUST
CURIOUS. ALL RIGHT. SO WE HAVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR GROVE. WE HAVE
A Dð PASS, AND WE RECOMMEND AYE
VOTE. SO, SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL TO BE ADOPTED TO THE
SENATE FLOOR. BRADFORD.
BRADFORD. AYE. DALLY. DALLY AYE.
ASHBY. BECKER. BECKER. AYE
CABALLERO. DODD. AYE. DODD. AYE
DURAZO. EGGMAN. EGGMAN. AYE.
GONZALEZ GROVE. GROVE. AYE.
LEMON MIN A MIN. AYE. NEWMAN.
NEWMAN. AYE. RUBIO. CIERTO.
CIERTO AYE. SKINNER. STERN.
WILK. AYE WILK. AYE. IT HAS TEN
VOTES. THE MEASURE HAS TEN
VOTES. WILL LEAVE THE ROLL OPEN
FOR THE NEXT TEN MINUTES. FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS TO ADD ON. SO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND WE'LL DEFINITELY PUT YOU ON
AS COAUTHORS AT ASKED AND CAN
LET OUR OFFICE KNOW IF ANYONE
ELSE WOULD LIKE TO JUMP ON. GOT
THAT. GREAT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. APPRECIATE YOU TAKING THE
TIME TODAY. THANK YOU.
IF YOU VOTE, YOU'RE FREE TO GIVE.
TO WE'RE STILL IN THE ENERGY
COMMITTEE. SO I'M GOING TO ASK
THAT WE OPEN THE ROLL FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS AT THIS TIME TO ADD ON.
OKAY. H.R. 18, DAVIS TO BE
ADOPTED IN ORDER TO THE SENATE
FLOOR. CURRENT VOTE TEN ZERO.
ASHBY ASHBY. AYE. CABALLERO
DURAZO GONZALEZ. LIMON. RUBIO.
SKINNER STERN. 11 TO 0. ALL
RIGHT. THAT MEASURE HAS H.R. 18
HAS 11 VOTES, THAT WILL CONCLUDE
OUR HEARING. I JUST WANT TO
THANK EVERYBODY FOR
PARTICIPATING IN TODAY'S
HEARING. AND THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON ENERGY, UTILITIES
AND COMMUNICATIONS IS NOW
ADJOURNED.